Please. Parti politic.
Hi, my dear pirate colleagues,
I have a one message today to share with you.
Increasing the number and share of women in politics
and executive positions
is undoubtedly
one of the missions of our generation of female politicians
that we strongly aim to finally complete.
Looking at some percentages and arguments of conservatives,
one must ask oneself,
is there really just one qualified woman pair four qualified men?
Hardly so. We women don't have it easy in politics.
We are targets of constant evaluation.
It seems that every single woman in politics
is the representation of all other women.
And our appearance is being constantly disgust and evaluated.
Our outfit is either too boring or too challenging,
and it's just very demanding.
I used to try and survive in this system
by trying to be the most informed person in the room
when going to negotiate,
but that is just supporting the idea of female perfection.
Now I'm trying to just stay true to myself,
with my faults and my strengths.
In addition,
I think it's really a duty of us who have reached the higher positions
to lead by example,
inspire other women to join politics and join the fight.
And I'm really happy that I can talk to you today,
especially to my French female pirate colleagues,
together with Caroline, uh,
whom I hope I will meet
as my new colleague in the European Parliament next term.
It's really worth the fight.
And the More of us there are there,
the more bearable it will be for everyone.
Thank you. And strength. You